el último debate antes de las
presidenciales del 24 de abril en
francia emmanuel mccrone imagine lepén
enfrentados a segunda vuelta expusieron
sus ideas sobre los temas más
controversiales de la campaña macri
acusó al epen de un supuesto conflicto
de intereses de la calidad a quien
habría pedido un préstamo a rusia ahora
hablé de un punto preciso que tiene que
ver con el financiamiento de su partido
lo que dije es falso señor penn
sí señor marco es falso y es bastante
público entonces
yo me veo obligada a sacar este
préstamos en el extranjero si todo el
mundo del odio sabe eso lo sabe todo el
mundo fui a buscar el préstamo en el
exterior porque ningún banco francés me
quiso conceder un préstamo la migración
también fue el centro del cara a cara
decisiones lepén propuso un referendo
para ver si los franceses estaban de
acuerdo para dejar entrar a los
refugiados la inmigración anárquica y
masiva contribuye a la grabación de la
inseguridad en nuestro país esa es la
razón por la cual voy a proponerle a los
franceses un referéndum de estos
seguramente hablaremos más adelante para
con el fin de cambiar radicalmente la
política de inmigración para que al fin
simplemente los franceses decidan tiempo
de venir quien se puede quedar y quién
se debe ir propuso además una
prohibición total del hiyab el velo
islámico mientras macrón se opone hay en
nuestro país un islamismo en mi opinión
y
combatido con las políticas que usted ha
establecido entonces hay que tener una
ley contra la ideología islamista pienso
que no hemos sido lo suficientemente
firmes en este tema yo estoy a favor de
la interdicción de los solteros en el
espacio público ya lo he dicho
claramente pienso que el velo es un
uniforme
primero que todos los escucho y lo dice
con mucha claridad una demostración de
lo que me preocupa en su demostración es
el camino que toma
sobre un tema sobre el velo llevó al
terrorismo para volver al islamismo y
para ir a los extranjeros
y usted crea un sistema de equivalencias
en este camino que confunde todos los
problemas y que los mantiene nos el
cambio climático también causa chacón
fuertes e interesante al escucharla es
la incoherencia de la conversación
porque conducen hablas de vos
hablar del modelo económico de las
importaciones las importaciones que nos
restan más problemas en términos de
déficit económico y en términos de
balance son esta dependencia de los
hidrocarburos y usted propuso la mayor
subvención para los hidrocarburos porque
usted quiere reducir el iva sobre estos
hidrocarburos entonces su programa no
tiene ni cola ni cabeza usted es una
escéptica del clima
nada soy escéptica con respecto al clima
nunca pero quizás usted es un poco
hipócrita respecto al clima por eso es
que las personas no creen en su voluntad
de resolver todos estos problemas porque
ellos tienen razón que es lo peor de la
ecología punitiva y usted ha sentido
cosas que son violentas para las clases
medias y modestas de nuestros
compatriotas
de pena aprovechó para criticar las
políticas sobre el manejo de la pandemia
del gobierno de macrón uno de los puntos
que se le critica al presidente de cara
a estas elecciones